so I was trying to come up the time of
this presentation I thought youtube and
education pretty much says it all I
think it adds the the mind races that
the potential here and you know thinking
about it what is YouTube doing with
education well I think it's already used
heavily for education I think that many
students are already using it it's a
primary resource fine video for their
work faculty everyone is it's basically
a beach to critical mass now where
there's almost a infinite choice but a
heck of a lot to find what you're
looking for I think that it's truly
evolved beyond pure entertainment
platform and also a place people come to
be informed and be inspired so I'm just
going to give a little bit of background
ok so this quote is from of your comment
on UC Berkeley's site on google video
education is moving in a new direction
it's no longer simply for those who can
attend University it's open for anyone
who has the initiative to seize it so i
should say it's full disclosure I joined
Google and YouTube in December a
previous to that I work at UC Berkeley
for six years so there's paying close
attention to this kind of commentary
this is just a snapshot of UC Berkeley's
site its video google.com / UC Berkeley
and it launched in late September and I
think it launched with about 250 videos
it's up to about 350 now including six
full courses special events and some
sports I should add that I think the
most highly trafficked are the course
material I think it has a little over
one quarter million views to date the
view is a basically you go to page and
it automatically plays back and it got
great press it was on the front page of
the San Jose Mercury News which is the
local paper in Silicon Valley SF gay and
numerous blogs so where Google video is
today visa V youtube so Google video is
really
hoping to be more of a search platform
for video perspective of where it's
hosted on the web where YouTube is
really that primary site for hosting
delivery at and in course community
interaction okay so YouTube YouTube
audience is tremendous just a show of
hands how many people here have watched
a video on youtube okay the only the
only guy who did it was consensus pocket
or should have said and I'm not going to
bother reason how many folks here have
uploaded a video to YouTube okay great
it's interesting ratio viewership is in
the hundreds of millions per day and
upload is in the hundreds of thousands
so I think that that's a pretty good
split for when we're seeing here in the
audience one thing about this this a
massive amount of viewership is a lot of
it is also international of course and
YouTube is really becoming a window to
the world and I think that as it evolves
we it's a really fertile ground to put
on some very great material to educate
obviously and so I'll get to that in a
bit about how we could potentially work
together to make that happen okay so
this is a this is what's known as a
branded channel using BBC as an example
and I'll show a few other examples and
just a quick breakdown of what this is
so for our strategic partners it's your
regular YouTube account but with
additional branding opportunities
there's the leaderboard at the top we
see BBC World News it actually is a can
be a link that links back to your
website or two sub channels within
YouTube it also could be an image map as
well let me just go choose another one
here this is a Google's branded channel
which I chose because you'll see this
particular video is a lecture that lasts
for a little over
our so with our strategic partnerships
their long-form video is possible though
we do see a viewership dropped after a
very short periods
so ask you later why that's it funny
okay so this is a watch page this is
where the playback happens of course
additional branding opportunities this
is obviously the NBA you see where says
i love this game it's a basically this
is kind of the parent-child relationship
from the branded channel to the to the
watch page obviously the comments or
responses this is really that the really
the two-way engagement that makes
YouTube so exciting and also you'll see
the more from this user as an area where
essentially the NBA is treated as a user
so this is where other videos I'm from
this particular provider appear playlist
is where you can specifically sequence
your videos either front they are from
the producer our provider or also mixed
a mixed variety of content so a little
bit more about the community what's
interesting about YouTube is just how
nonlinear it is typically the entry
point to YouTube is it necessarily the
youtube com homepage as it is that
somebody is with sent a link to an email
they'll go to the site to watch a video
then they start to stick around and see
other videos are being promoted and or
related and so on so the discovery is a
is quite organic this is an example this
is actually a warner music group I show
it because it's a I think the best
representation of how to deal with
multiple sub-channels so music label
many artists so analog here to
university there might have any
different faculty members departments
and so on again that leaderboard at the
top is an image map so you can they keep
it so you link directly to that artists
particular page
why on that one so this is a fairly new
category called how to do it yourself
and this is where you learn to cook or I
don't know what do we have here how to
gain them youtube subscribers that you
name it and it's a new and really really
growing rapidly and I point to because
it's really the closest thing we have
today to an educational channel I want
to pick one out in particular when I
found here in the featured have to
called math crazy tutoring where this
fellow basically put some basic math and
English topics online and let me see
what happens if i go to the page going
to work so what's interesting about this
is you'll see oops that the students are
also posting their videos and just go to
one in particular calls it a national
initiative important letter stating
publishes okay and some of the ratings
are interesting can you do more
complicated functions that when
involving divisions thank you and so on
yet please more so um people are giving
his fellow feedback and then he modifies
his programming to defend it so see if i
can get back
so with the partnerships also comes the
ability to have promotion again
typically somebody comes to the site
they watch a video and then their
eyeballs are looking around and what's
the next video they're going to watch
and they often fall on these director
slots here so again our strategic
partners get promoted over here but it's
really a mix of our strategic partners
as well as our original originally
created content so i think was last week
google announced it was on his universal
search where you saw on a search term is
a combination of obviously text websites
as well as results from books or scholar
video and so on and so these are some
examples on the left is google com on
the right is google video this is a eric
schmidt recently speaking at stanford
the web 20 conference and what's
interesting about this is that the
YouTube player is right there in in the
Google search results page and the
google video on the right is um
similarly similarly does that obviously
it's owned in specifically on a video
that applies in in in google so i think
i'm coming to the end this is an
interesting quote this is a Larry Page
co-founder of Google speaking to a group
of scientists about how to better market
themselves and says this is from cnet
news page said he hopes internet video
like YouTube a google video will evolve
to include scientific lectures he said
he would like to see a box in the back
of every classroom where professors
could push a button and whatever you
said would go on the net it's important
to get all that out there so obviously
here is a great opportunity to to
promote institution in your archive to
lend the discoverability and what what I
also think is that since this is
relatively new in YouTube that is real
chance to help
and been to space and and you know I
guess that's it so I'll leave it at that
keep it short and sweet